in the last video we started on this
problem right here where we said let
Omega be a complex cube root of unity
and Omega cannot be equal to 1 and so we
figured out what all of the complex cube
roots of unity were we figured out well
we knew that one was one of them and we
used that to factor out this this third
degree equation right over here we
figured out the other the other roots
cube roots of unity were negative 1 plus
or minus the square root of 3i over 2
and we said what the problem said let
let Omega be one of them or be a complex
cube root of unity so I just picked it
to be the negative version so I said let
ol megha be this thing right over here
now and just as just to kind of explore
the space a little bit we said ok what's
omega squared and we figured out that it
was actually the conjugate of this it's
the plus version of this so we got we
got Omega squared right over here and
then I kind of wasted your time a little
bit because we know what Omega cubed is
we know that Omega is a cube root of
unity so Omega cubed must be unity but
it wasn't it wasn't harmful I guess to
go through the process it shows you
sometimes my brain gets into a rut and
just goes does stuff that it doesn't
have to do but we figured out we
multiply this times Omega to show that
hey it is definitely equal to 1 so we're
able to do is set up a situation and we
will use this to think about the next
part of the problem
so Omega Omega is equal to negative 1/2
or maybe I should say Omega to the first
power is equal to negative 1/2 minus the
square root of 3 over 2 I Omega to the
second power Omega to the second power
let me write it over here Omega to the
second power is equal to negative 1 plus
the square root of 3 over 2i and then
Omega to the third power then that was
pretty straightforward is equal to 1 and
I touched on this in the last video what
is Omega to the fourth power Omega to
the fourth power is going to be Omega to
the third times Omega so it's going to
be Omega again so this is also going to
be this is also let me scroll to the
left a little bit this is also going to
be Omega to the fourth power Omega to
the fourth power is the same thing as
Omega to the first power which is this
now what's to the fifth power what's
going to be Omega times the fourth power
so it's a
times this well Omega times this is the
same thing as Omega squared so it's
going to be that so this is omega this
is omega to the fifth power and what's
Omega to the sixth power well that's
just the same thing as taking Omega
cubed and squaring it so this is also
going to be one so this is Omega to the
sixth or you could just use its this
times Omega right because this is a
fifth power and we saw that that's also
equal to one so we did set up and the
reason why I went up to the sixth power
is because if you'll remember the old
problem
we're rolling a die and on that die I'm
assuming it's a normal six-sided die
we're gonna get values between 1 and 6
and we're gonna take Omega to the
different powers and we're going to see
if it equals to 0 and we want to find
the probability of this being equal to
zero so let me write this down we want
to find the probability we want to find
the probability that Omega and we're
just using the Omega that we pick
because they said it's one of the
complex roots that isn't one so we want
to find the probability that Omega to
the the first the first die of the role
plus Omega to the second die of the role
plus Omega to the third die of the role
that when you take their sum that that
is equal to zero
this is what we need to figure out so to
figure this out let's just figure out
what what combinations of powers of
Omega will even add up to zero how can
we even add them up to zero
none of these you know I mean they they
all have to cancel out some way and if
you look at them it looks pretty
interesting of how they might cancel out
if I take one version of this the only
way that they really can cancel out is
if I take one version of this and add it
to this and then add it to this let me
show you if I take negative if I take
negative 1/2 negative one half minus
square root of 3 over 2i and I add it to
this and I add it to this negative one
half plus a square root of 3 over 2i and
then I add it to 1 and then I add it to
this and then I add it to this what do I
get
well you're going to have this this guy
and this guy are going to cancel out
negative one half plus negative one half
is our going to be equal to our going to
be equal to negative one yeah negative
one to one it's going to be equal to
zero so essentially what we're going to
do it where we're asked what it's asking
us what's the probability that I get
four for each of these terms then I get
one each of each of these powers of
Omega or another way of thinking about
this what's the what's the probability
so if we think of it this way so R 1 R 1
let's think of it this way R 1 could be
equal to we could get if we say that
this is going that we're gonna get Omega
here we're gonna get which is the same
thing as Omega to the fourth power so
this is could be R 1 could be one or for
R 2 R 2 and this is in the situation
where the first one gives us Omega the
second one is Omega squared or the
second one gives us this value and then
the third one gives us 1 so R 2 would be
5 or 2 our two would be 5 or 2 and then
R 3 R 3 would be equal to R 3 would be
equal to 3 or 6 3 or 6 now I want to be
very clear we could we could swap these
around there's actually 6 there's
actually 6 ways that you could you could
instead of instead of this being the
first role this role could be 1 or 4 and
then this one could be 5 or 2 and then
this one could be 3 or 6 so there's
actually 6 ways of doing this I guess
you could say you could permute these 6
6 different ways or 3 times 2 times 1
but we'll think about that in a second
but let's just assuming that we want
this way where this first one this first
one is going to evaluate to this and the
second one is going to evaluate to this
and the third one is going to evaluate
to this what's the probability of that
happening and then we're going to
multiply that six by six because there's
six ways to rearrange these terms right
over here so let's do that so what's the
probability of that happening well the
probability the probability that R 1 is
a 1 or 4 well that's 2 values out of 6
so the probability is 1/3 there the
probability that R 2 is a 5 or 2 well
that's also going to be 1/3 there's two
values out of a possible of 6 the
probability that R 3 is a 3 or 6 only
two possibilities there so two out of
six possible
faces of the dyso times 1/3 so the
probability the probability that this
first one is going to evaluate the first
one is going to evaluate to our to this
value right over here the second one is
going to evaluate to this value and the
third one's going to evaluate to one is
going to be 1/3 times 1/3 times 1/3
which is 1 over 27
now let me be and I touched on this
already this is there's six ways that
you could you could rearrange this six
ways there's there's three of you have
three terms and you're putting them in
three places so in the first place in
the first place you could put three of
the terms and the second place you could
you have two terms left that you could
put and in the last place you only have
one term left so there's three times two
times one ways to arrange these things
we can arrange this three times two
times one different ways so there's six
different arrangements the probability
of each is one over 27 so the
probability under question this thing
over here there are six arrangements
there are six arrangements of getting of
getting these things to be added up in
this way and the probability of each of
them is 1 over 27 so it's equal to 6
over 27 and if you divide the numerator
and the denominator by 3 it's equal to 2
over 9 and we're done it wasn't too bad
I think the probability the probability
of getting Omega to the R 1 plus Omega
to the R 2 plus Omega there are 3 where
R 1 and R 2 R 3 are rolls numbers
obtained from rolling a fair die the
problem is when you add all of these
it's going to be equal to 0 is 2 over 9
any method that was pretty neat problem